I mean I would confirm it was romantic
to this day you guys don't know dated
this guy Megan Fox and Tyra Banks
dropped some major dating bombshells on
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
so it was like an onset romance that
didn't go anywhere afterwards it's been
more than a decade since the first
Transformers film was released romantic
thing that I'm not trying to do Shawn
but during a game of plead the fifth Fox
was asked about a 2011 interview her
co-star Shia LaBeouf did in which he
claimed they had shared a romantic
relationship on the set of the film I
mean I would confirm his romantic I love
him I've never been like really quiet
about that I love him the 32 year old
actress is now married to Brian Austin
Green whom she shares three sons with
the two tied the knot in 2010 and have
had their fair share of ups and downs in
fact Fox didn't shy away from revealing
the craziest thing she's ever done while
fighting with her man one time I got
really angry at him and I wrote in
sharpie marker a bunch of like Nietzsche
poems all over his walls
then it was banks his turn to spill the
tea the 44 year old supermodel got
candid about finding love in her DMS
after Cohen asked how often people try
to spark a love connection with her on
social media I read you love da I dated
a very famous recording artist because
he hit me up in the DM really but I
would go like into the restaurant first
and then he would go in after or we'd go
into restaurants that nobody knows and
to this day you guys don't know dated
this guy Fox tried to guess the identity
of the mystery man we have to guess no
no we have one good one hand Cynthia
will get one break no but banks wasn't
budging in October 2017 a source
confirmed to et that banks had split
from photographer Erik asla after five
years of dating the two had been
together since 2013 and welcome to son
via surrogacy last January at the time
of their split the source told et
quote there was no drama at all they are
still friends and co-parenting their son
York banks Allah together
[Music]